A24 was the studio that brought us my favorite
horror film of 2017, It Comes At Night, and
judging from what people have been saying
about this movie at Sundance, it sounds like
their new film, Hereditary, could be another
success.
Yesterday we got a trailer for it and it does
look promising.
Look closer however and you'll see some downright
creepy details and things that just don't
add up... seemingly on purpose...
If you want to hear the one consistency I
did find, then make sure to stick around to
the end of this video.
This is Things You Missed.
Let's just start at the beginning of the trailer.
It opens on this miniature model of the house.
It appears to be the house that they live
in which shows up about midway through the
trailer.
This piece sitting on the chair should end
up going right here on the front of the house.
The garage doors are the same for both.
And the front entrance and the overall shape
of the house seem consistent.
But then you notice this window is missing
from the model and the colors are changed
entirely -- the model has beige wood and green
frames while the house is brown with dark
brown frames.
In another shot we can also confirm that the
real house is missing this section too.
Now it could just be that she's using the
miniature to plan to a remodel or something,
or she's an architect, as evidenced by these
blueprints, that reuses the same design elements
in many of her works, such as the garage door
and the front door.
But what makes me think otherwise is that
there are other inconsistencies in the trailer
begging to be noticed.
The treehouse is missing from the model altogether,
and because the treehouse looks like a small,
separate house house, you have to wonder if
she just sees it as another one of her creations.
Just a crazy guess here because we don't know
a whole lot about this movie yet, but maybe
the mother starts to break down later in the
movie and loses sight of the difference between
her real family and the figurines.
One more thing from this opening shot before
we move on.
There are two creepy photos pinned up in the
corner of the room.
I'm not sure what the first one is, but please
let me know your thoughts in the comments.
But the second one looks like a pair of feet
standing in an overexposed doorway.
If you're not convinced let me crank up the
contrast for you.
Now let's look at this shot later in the trailer
where the Mom finds the figurine of her deceased
mother standing in the doorway.
Connection?
Not definite.
But absolutely a possibility.
Here's another inconsistency.
Outside of the immediate family, which is
these guys, none of the people at the burial
are the same people who attend the service.
See how there are a bunch of bearded guys
at the service?
None at the burial.
See these bald guys at the burial?
Not at the service.
The burial has four kids.
The only kid at the service is the daughter.
As far as I can tell, the immediate family
are the only ones to attend both events.
The mother even comments, "it's heartening
to see so many strange new faces here today.
I know my mom would be very touched."
What does that even mean?
Why would you want strangers at your mother's
funeral?
Like I said, something doesn't add up.
But it gets weirder...
The daughter is drawing a picture of her mother
hysterical and crying at the podium.
But we see at the podium, the mom is fine.
It's at the burial that she's hysterical.
Also, on the other page, what is this?
This is terrifying!
If these drawings turn out to be telling of
things to come, then this is going to be one
freaky scene.
The necklace the mother wears can also be
seen on the dead grandma as well, so it could
be a symbol for the hereditary passing down
of traits -- just as biological genes are
passed down, the tradition of the necklace
could also be passed down.
What I couldn't figure out is what this shape
is supposed to be.
Let me know your interpretation, but as far
as I can tell, there are three consecutive
figures, possibly signifying daughter, mother
and grandmother.
This next one is just more disturbing when
you think more about it.
Why did this woman make a tiny model of her
own mother on her deathbed?
I shutter to think of what kind of person
does this.
And if that wasn't strange enough, it looks
like the daughter also draws the dead grandma.
This family needs a new hobby.
And if I'm not mistaken, it looks like the
Grandma's eyes are opening on the other page,
which is out of focus, which again will be
very unsettling if true.
Maybe you all picked this up right away, but
this next thing is another one that just got
creepy after I thought about it for a second.
"You know you were always her favorite right?
Even when you were a little baby.
She wouldn't let me feed you because she needed
to feed you.
Because she needed to feed you.
Because she needed to feed you."
Hopefully they were talking about baby formula
but let's face it.
It's way too late for that.
Here are some weird things I noticed about
the daughter.
She's always wearing orange.
She always has these strings tied around her
finger.
And she's got this weird connection with birds.
A bird crashes into her classroom window.
She cuts a bird's head off with scissors.
Totally normal.
She has pictures of birds in her room.
There's also a bird ornament sitting in a
nest in her room.
You could even say her whole room kind of
resembles a bird house.
If you think of a birdhouse as a miniature
house that hangs on a tree, so is this.
Speaking of her room, first of all, super
cool.
What kid would not want to live in that?
But on the inside...
well this guy's just lovely.... and what's
the point of having indoor wind chimes anyway?
I think that's enough of the girl for now...
she's kind of freaky.
Let's move on to the son.
I don't know if it's just me, but he looks
way older than his classmates.
I mean look at this kid.
Look at her.
Now look at the son.
Looks like he got held back a couple times,
but given what happens next I can kind of
see why.
Also there's a poster on the wall behind him
that just says "BIG".
It could be because everything in this movie
seems to have a miniature version, and if
the lines between the two do start to blur
at some point as I predicted, there may be
clues about which world we are in.
I think we've established that the kid is
kind of disturbed, so this sign at the school
that has the words HELP?
and counselor probably foreshadow a scene
that takes place at said counselor's office
involving the kid.
You may have noticed in this quick shot that
the head from this doll is missing, but what
you most likely overlooked, is that this is
actually supposed to be the son, Peter.
The dresser right here is the same as this
dresser seen in his room, and the position
of the bed in relation to his desk also matches.
The shade of the blue pajamas seems to be
the same as what the doll is wearing and the
color of the walls and the location of this
stripe all match up.
But of course there had to be inconsistencies
like the missing blinds or the added carpet.
I think we can assume that his head smashing
tendencies are probably related to why the
doll has no head, but it also looks like something
is trying to pull his head off just before.
And as promised, there is one major consistency
that could be a big clue as to what's making
this family so crazy.
At the end of the trailer, this flare transitions
the mother's face into the daughter.
A similar flair is seen traveling down the
hall at the son's school.
I'd love to hear your thoughts about this,
so let me know what you think in the comments.
If you're looking forward to Hereditary, then
leave this video a like.
If you're too scared, check out my comedy-horror
web-series The Wokking Dead instead.
But regardless of your choice, I'm going to
be covering all the best horror content of
2018, so make sure that you subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I'll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.
What?